Whoa, I'm tiny!
Look at me, I'm tiny!
Why am I so tiny?
What the fuck?
I don't know how I fucked that up.
Look at me, I'm baby.
Holy shit, I was so tiny guys.
It was called optical illusion right there.
Let me fix this.
I'm gonna do a magic trick again, guys.
That was my second magic trick.
Look, wait, give me a second.
I also love you thinking for the five bits.
Thinking Fogget tier three for five months in a row.
Woo!
Can I get some bark nights real quick for Fogget?
Let me fix this real quick.
My thingy's broken a bit.
I'll do a magic trick.
Watch this.
Boop.
I
wonder what friendship could be.
Until you all shared its magic with me.
Crimbo, thank you for the tier 2 as well, whoa, give me some
birth nights for Crimbo and Foghead today, holy shit,
alright, so let me, let me say hi to, oh, that was so tiny,
I have no idea, I don't know how I fucked up, I always fuck
up somehow, but every time I start stream, I would like,
spend like, five minutes trying to make sure I don't, but it
always happens, it doesn't matter how many times I prepare
myself, I'll fuck up anyway, so I was like, let me say hi to
everyone, Juki, Liquid, Matio, Ice, uh who else sneak uh
sneaking victor zino crimbo fogget lancer uh major cryptic
azure fogget fluffy i know i think i pretty much repeated
people's names already i already forgot who i said hi
gilgamesh acid starry el crunchy nintendo a box pdf hello
everyone hi hi hi hi hi tree top hi guys okay so guys you're
fine i hope you're having fine art today too I was so tiny
dude I that was magic all right so let me tell you guys
about what I know about this game um I know nothing about
this game I just know it's a puzzle game and um I was like
damn I had four hours of sleep guys do you think I could do
this puzzle game with four hours of a flip-flop for you,
Vox.
Oh, thank you.
Okay.
Can we help you?
I mean, sure, please.
I think I need all the help I can get.
Yeah, I...
Okay, this game can then use flashing lights.
Alright, I just won't look it.
Sure, why not?
See, it's easy.
All you need to know is up, equals big, down, equals small.
Yeah.
Are you filled with feelings of self-doubt?
Alright, cool.
Do you find yourself prone to minimizing massive dilemmas?
Or for allowing the smallest problems to get blown
completely out of proportion what the fuck don't diagnose me
no it's a puzzle game
really thank you so much for the tier tier one three one sub
whoa can you get some break nights real quick for a ruby
thank you thank you guys holy shit i i don't know what i
honestly have no is about all i know is it's a puzzle game
and i was like i don't i feel like i feel like watch i was
like oh w-a-s-d mount only okay so what what what what i
can't even read the okay who the fuck reads terms of
services anyway and no one watching it no one reads terms of
services Anyway, I just I just automatically signed it.
So All right, oh What's this perception is reality Oh
Oh, how did I shrink it?
How do I shrink it?
Oh, oh my god.
Oh shit.
Okay, okay Oh Oh, I get it.
I get it.
I get so I can I can make it smaller.
Wait, can I jump?
I can make it even smaller Like how small can I make this?
Terms of service accepted congratulations on you make things
bigger small by changing to some perspectives.
Oh shit Oh my gosh.
I'm big.
I'm big too.
Okay.
My thing zoomed in I don't know why I might wait.
Let me fix this.
I don't know Why this is fucking up real quickly.
I'm fixing my thingy.
I don't know why this is fucking up.
This is weird I'm so scuffed chat.
I You don't have to know what the fuck I'm doing.
I went from big to small to big.
Yo, yo, it won't let me.
I don't know how big is it.
Okay, fuck it.
It's fine.
I'll just go look at this.
Oh, hey guys.
Hey.
Hey guys?
I hope you guys are having...
Alright, I'm not thinking so much of the follow.
Thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Have a butt art.
Thank you.
Or I can do it like this.
Whoa, hey.
Look at me.
It's called Perception.
Perception right here.
It's like it's really...
It's actually interactive.
Oh my god.
Treetop, thank you so much for the five gifted subs!
Thank you, see, wait, wait, let me zoom back in.
Thank you so much for the five...
Hey, thank you, Treetop, for the five gifted subs.
You're gonna get some bark nights real quick.
We're here for Treetop for gifted five subs.
Thank you, thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Woo!
Thank you so much.
Okay, wait, what was I supposed to do?
I was not...
Oh, shit, I was not listening to anything.
oh wait wait oh okay so apparently it takes like uh it takes
like uh two hours to finish this game so this is gonna take
me like five minutes practically oh i gotta make the way you
finish or how did i make this big big big did i bring this
here the close-up is hilarious well
I'm stupid I'm gonna take thank you so much a thousand bits
thank you holy shit guys I didn't even I don't even know
what I'm doing I'm so I'm so tired I'm so tired right now I
don't know what the fuck I'm doing right now thank you so
much for the thousand well Oh, you're so tiny.
Does far make big?
Or is it close make big?
No, it's far makes big, right?
Far is big.
Far is, far is, I don't know perspective.
Hey, I draw for a living.
I still don't, I still don't know.
Did I look up?
Oh,
if I look up, it goes big.
Oh!
Oh my god, my brain.
I didn't even I didn't even read that comment, Chrissy.
I thought about that before before you said anything.
I didn't need your help.
Okay, maybe.
Okay.
Look at that.
I'm so I'm so.
Oh, I can confirm.
You can move freely interact with surrounding objects and
listen to messages from your patient care team.
Please note that I am the standard orientation protocol.
That the sun don't move that way.
I don't want you.
I do not care.
Thank you so much for the fall, Izzy.
Wait, I didn't listen.
What do you say?
Do I just leave?
Okay, I'll just leave.
I guess I'll just leave.
Oh wait, wait, what?
What do you do with you?
Oh.
Oh, that's too big.
Wait, whoa, what the fuck?
What the fuck?
Okay, okay, I need to be tinier.
Okay, yo, street, oh, wait.
Can I throw it?
Okay, please, please my arms.
Oh, oh, oh, okay, wait, wait.
Oh, work!
Please, please, sir, please!
Why can't I throw it?
There we go.
Wasn't even that hard.
It wasn't even that hard.
Hold right.
Now I can right rotate.
I am so...
Dude.
What do I do with this?
Oh!
Can I make it bigger?
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
That freaking...
Yo, I'm gonna speed...
Yo, oh my god, this speedruns this game.
Oh, I'm dead.
Crunchy, thank you so much for getting this up.
Yeah, I think I'm dead.
Then guys, Adrian, thank you for the fall.
How did I break the game?
I don't, what?
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Maybe I can make a speed run.
Speed run strat.
All right.
All right, wait, wait, wait.
Let me see if I can do it.
Let me see.
Let me see if I can.
Yeah, see.
I don't break it anymore.
Look.
It's okay.
Oh my god, that's a big ass cheese.
That's a big ass cheese.
During eyelids, you will lose the ability to awaken suddenly
due to realizing that this is a dream.
Breaking cheese keeps you...
I have already informed you that this is a dream.
You did not wake up.
Please complete the remaining orientation activities.
It won't let me break it.
It won't let me break the game anymore.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Are you small?
stress wait why is it so small then break it again does it
not go big anymore i think i broke it again it's not going
oh oh that's a big ass she's here next to the wall i think
all right it's not gonna let you choose it anymore oh wait
wait how do i get up okay all right there we go it's not
going He doesn't let me go big anymore.
Alright, rotate time.
Rotate time.
Oh, am I rotate?
Rotate?
Rotate.
Alright.
Okay, here we go.
Please.
Oh my god, how am I stuck at the cheese level?
Okay, wait.
Okay, oh, there we go.
okay there we go there you go I got it hi dynamic thank you
so much for the follow thank you thank you thank you have a
have a but heart thank you thank you so much okay it's gonna
let me cheese honey what is this 12 o 5 is it 12 o 5 I was
fucking idiot it's 12 3 7 a.m.
okay too what can I do here am I stuck I'm Oh, warning you
have deviated from the orientation pathway at the Pierce
Institute patient safety as a key node in our corporate
Priority tetrahedron a variable degree of force can and will
be authorized to ensure patient safety please return to the
orientation If I stay here does it force me out are you
booked the game once you think I won't break it again?
Okay, fuck it.
I can't be fucking bothered
Unless...
What can I do here?
Oh, I thought I could break this.
Oh shit!
Okay, no, that was a word.
Drink a soda.
How did I drink a soda?
Oh shit!
Oh,
can we go bigger?
Can we go bigger?
Oh, bigger.
Bigger.
How big can this soda get?
Did that do anything?
Oh, shit.
How big can you get soda?
Oh, my God.
This is a big ass soda.
I wonder what do I do with you.
What do I do with you?
I don't know what to do with this.
Okay.
Okay, I see.
So now, instead of some diabetes, we're in extreme thirst.
Oh, what the f- Oh shit.
Okay, how do I get through here?
Oh.
Oh, I need tiny soda.
Wait, unless...
That actually worked.
Bring my soda with me.
Tiny plaque.
Oh.
My soda.
Oh, that's stupid.
I can't bring soda.
Is this a horror game?
What the fuck?
Let me make it small again.
Oh, wait.
I have Arizona.
Okay, I'm making this small.
Okay, wait.
As soon you will see.
Please don't tell me this is the horror game.
I was not.
I'm not prepared for that.
Maybe?
Maybe.
Oh.
Oh, you're so tiny now.
Can I crouch?
Oh, no.
this is oh no no please please I can't take here what do you
want me to do please please get in here what's that body no
no please please just make small and put up what do you mean
I'm I'm putting it all up Okay, is there another hole here?
Okay, not here.
Maybe.
Okay, maybe.
Oh.
Wait, wait, let me put the button earlier.
Dude, I'm just like, honestly, I'm just brute forcing it.
I'm brute forcing everything until it works.
This game is like Layers of Fear.
I want you to accept that I play it and I check it out in
episode 3 of Nightmares for a week.
All environments perceived during eyelids should reflect a
typical mental state.
If you believe your mental state was compromised by
Somnaskult, please provide a comprehensive rational
explanation in your post-procedural survey.
It's precisely a size relative to the object.
It's put a gift card.
You're using words I don't.
You're using too many, too many big words for me right now.
How do I get this in here?
Dude, I'm an artist, too.
And I don't know shit about perspective.
What the fuck?
Let me in.
Where this is open?
Where this...
What?
Hello?
Oh my god, dude, my god.
Please, please, come over.
I'm so fucking confused.
Please, give me the block.
Hey, rocket.
Okay, maybe if I bring it here.
Okay, no.
Okay, wait, unless, wait.
Oh, oh.
Wait!
Okay.
Alright.
Ugh.
God, I'm so fucking sorry.
This is the only game we back see.
I was reading chat.
I just didn't understand what the fuck you're talking about.
I just- I didn't know- I was like over the- over you stupid.
There's a window.
How am I gonna put it over?
There's a fucking window.
I was thinking, damn, my chat's so fucking stupid.
Can't believe they don't know that there's a window here.
Objects can't go through windows.
Guy.
Oh my gosh, I think I'm lost now.
Where am I?
Wait, what is there?
Wait.
Oh, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
Oh wait, I'm back here.
I'm so close to murder right now.
It hurts.
What are you guys talking about?
Am I stuck?
No.
Alright.
Yo, I'm so good.
And yo, I'm so good.
I don't know how I got here.
Huh?
Where's that opening?
Mabel turn it on the bracelet.
It is pretty.
It's pretty.
Oh!
How big can I make this?
Do you think I can break the game again?
Okay, I need to get it so it's on both sides.
It was still...
No, I gotta make this bigger.
Okay.
And then bigger.
We need to Use your nuggets, don't matter what.
No matter how stupid we are.
Press the fire.
Can I take the...
There's fire alarms here.
Please stand by for polite recognition on your completion of
the song.
Thank you so much for the four gifted songs!
Woo!
Okay, it's a breaknight deal quick for Jericho.
Thank you, thank you, thank you guys.
Holy shit, thank you.
I am so fucking tired.
I don't know what's going on.
I'm not listening to this girl talk.
I don't- Oh gosh.
Thank you so much for the follow, Edward.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Have a- have a- have a but heart.
Thank you so much.
Okay.
Oh?
Oh.
Cheese.
Wait, where the fuck did cheese come from?
Where did you come from?
So you're in joylessly while putting together a moniker by
Anchor of Crimpa.
What do you mean?
You're angry.
What the fuck do you mean?
Okay.
Oh!
Did I break it?
Oh.
Wait, wait, wait.
I got it.
Oh, okay.
No, I don't got this.
Here?
Hey.
It's simple, I anger.
Oh.
Why do you laugh so much though?
What do you mean?
But why would I need to rotate it?
Like...
Okay.
and I okay no that's not it wait do I uh but you seem like
so happy or something I'm laughing out pain no I'm not I'm
actually I'm actually so fucking depressed that laughing is
the only way to get the pain out why does it keep going
small what the fuck what the please
am I gonna do with this?
Oh, oh, okay.
Oh, okay.
Okay, I mean, that works.
Okay.
Just get angry and it'll work, I guess.
Brewports once again.
I don't know what I did.
I just, it's okay.
I never, I don't know what I'm doing.
If you don't know, just be angry, I guess.
No, where the fuck do I go?
She just makes it bigger.
She just makes...
Did
I win?
Just one more...
Does something happen?
Exactly.
I don't need to figure out shit out.
I don't need to use my brain.
All I have to do is just...
We won!
Woo!
Anyway, that was a great stream chat.
Yeah.
Wow, I had a great stream.
Crunchy!
Thank you so much!
Thank you so much, Crunchy for the tier one!
Two months in a row!
Woo!
Can I get some break nights real quick for Crunchy?
Thank you, thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
How long do you think the stream will actually- What do you
mean?
It's a 10-minute stream.
This game is two hours long, so it's practically 10 minutes.
Oh, no.
Cream soda.
Oh, shit.
Wait, I can have more than two now.
Is there gonna achieve...
What the fuck?
Okay, fire alarm.
Where's the fire alarm?
Where is it?
Where's the fire...
Oh!
Is that it?
Oh.
cool that's it apparently i can get an achievement if i
oh oh oh is it broken oh can i grab anything else
the sidebonds almost makes it worth it can it open doors is
how to lose brain cells what am i gonna do with this like it
tries to make something bigger it's like boy get bigger okay
i'm gonna make it big all right does it get better bigger
go big big okay it's stuck it's stuck on this one size
Grimbo!
Thank you so much for the...
Thank you so much for the $20.
Thank you, Grimbo.
Thank you.
Why am I tiny?
Perspective.
Thank you so much.
What the fuck?
What was that?
Oh my god, this game is giving me jumpscares.
Thank you again, Grimbo, for the $20.
Thank you guys.
I really do appreciate it.
lost.
There's only... Wait.
Oh!
Look at the baby door.
Wait!
Oh, I know what to do!
Wait.
I didn't make it small.
Okay.
Alright, baby door.
I wanted to put a...
Okay, I guess that wasn't the answer.
Baby door was not...
Baby door was not the answer.
Okay.
all right oh my god look at this door for ants look at baby
door what the fuck
baby door can i make it tinier oh what if i make it tinier
okay oh look at the baby door baby door holy fuck you know
i'm tired But I'm just looking, making baby doors.
Because it temporarily moved.
Don't talk to me on my baby door again.
Baby door, baby is door.
Holy shit.
This is like fucking sleep deprived humor right now, chat.
You know what?
Sleep deprivation humor.
Am I right?
Where the fuck am I?
Dude, I can't keep thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you, thank you.
Have a, have a, have a fun heart.
Thank you so much.
Maybe we'll have a baby.
What the fuck?
What is that?
You want to?
I go stream and laugh at the door.
Oh, that's trippy.
That is so trippy.
this is really tripping me out you
I did it that was really fucking trippy though wait do I go
up here you miss too far what the fuck what was that sound
whoa I'm tripping I'm not even on On his own, dude, that
was...
Alright.
Okay, big.
And then I do like this?
How did I rotate?
Oh.
Okay, maybe I'll make it bigger.
PBMA still crease me out even though we're past the...
The streets.
PBMA has a camp.
No, don't you fucking dare midnight.
Don't you fucking dare.
Cremwell, thank you again for another donation.
Thank you, Cremwell.
I really appreciate it, guys.
Oh, okay, I think this was too big.
I think maybe I made it too big
No, thanks so much for the fall I have a butthurt, thank you
What the fuck no, it's back to jazz back to piano What the
fuck I didn't even see what what I don't even know what was
supposed to be scary What what was it?
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry What the fuck every time I go up it changes look
Okay, stair con
Where am I supposed to go?
Really shows what music can do for your mood, right?
Now it's just fucking terrifying.
Oh.
Okay.
Can't bring it.
Wait, why is it tiny?
Okay.
I choose to sleep deprived for this!
Yo, me too!
Wait!
Oh my god, why are you tiny?
Let me just keep... okay.
Hello!
Oh!
My name is Dr. Glenn Pierce.
He is called a timer's five times his size.
Oh!
Danny's smooth!
But not to worry, spooky game is spooky.
again for the five dollars thank you thank you god crumble
thank you so much for all the donations
no i don't like this i don't i don't like i don't like how
it's okay be spooky sometimes mention something be too big
or too tiny okay um is this supposed to be Yeah, it's not
supposed- I fucking wonder like, oh, this is a very chill
and relaxing, very fun puzzle game.
It- it deals with optical illusions.
And I'm like, oh, that's- oh, where did you come from?
Wait, where did you come from?
Where- where did this come from?
Okay, I'll- I'll take it.
You hit the perspective.
I'm just not looking.
Where did it go?
Oh, there we go.
Didn't even need to try.
Dude, I don't think I'm, like, solving this puzzle.
These puzzles are right way.
I honestly think I'm just, I'm just, like, fucking around.
And in the puzzle game, just, we're like, oh, that man,
she's so smart.
She instantly figured out.
But no, I'm not even, like, fucking looking at it, shit.
And I'm not even looking at it.
and they're like looked out for a second it turns tidy
oh like this oh it was this oh so I wasn't even looking
where's the flower okay wait okay flower flower?
I'm so confused flower do I leave?
okay hi Eclipse hello another one Thank you and get for the
$5 scramble.
Thank you, thank you.
What's this?
I'm so, maybe if I move around, maybe, maybe the game will
feel bad for me.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, what's that?
I'm sorry.
What was that?
Who was that sound from?
Okay, maybe, maybe it, What?
I don't know!
I don't know where that came from!
I hit in the corner because I thought something...
What's going on?
What am I supposed to... Oh, oh, oh!
Oh my gosh, I'm so smart.
Oh.
Ta-da!
Wait, how do I make this big?
Have you got your cute little dino?
How do you get a cute dino badge?
I have too many badges, though.
Wait, why did it get small?
Cripple!
Thank you, Cripple!
Thank you, Brother 5!
Thank you, I really...
Cripple, I really appreciate all the donations.
Thank you so much.
I don't, how do I get him?
Where's like, where did I keep coming from?
Where is that coming from?
Go to the Twitch and type the email, refresh your page, go
to Dente, next to the, just go to Twitch.
Oh, okay, that's so much work.
That's so much work though.
That's so much work, I say.
as I'm struggling to make can I bring this over all right
exit oh
I can do this okay wait I can do this oh wait I can do I can
do this my perception is reality all right like this
Am I doing it?
Okay, I don't think I'm doing it.
Maybe I'm also on the other side.
Oh, that is platforming easy.
I'm fucking, I'm the worst at platforming games.
I'm actually one of the worst platformers.
Like, I'm so bad at platformers.
What the fuck do you want me to do?
Wait.
Wait, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, I know, I
know, I know.
My brain, my brain is...
brain is analyzing my brain.
I go up.
And then I do, and then I do this, right?
And holy shit, I'm so fucking smart.
Okay, I need, I need, it needs to be bigger.
It needs to be bigger.
Okay, it needs to be bigger.
All right, all right, all right.
It needs to be bigger.
It needs to be bigger It needs to be bigger It needs to be
Why is it not getting bigger?
Okay, okay, and then And then, and then Okay, I made it
small Okay, I made it small I accidentally made it Made it
small Okay, and then I do this, right?
And then And then I think I'm not, I don't think this is the
right answer.
I don't think I'm doing it right.
For some reason, I might not be doing this right.
Oh my god, Crimbo.
Another $5.
Thank you, Crimbo.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you for the donations.
You didn't have to.
I really appreciate it.
Okay, I'm so confused.
I am so fucking confused.
Okay, perception is reality.
Wait.
You gotta make the door?
How the fuck do you make a door?
Look at it!
Okay.
Okay, maybe...
We gotta make the door.
Can I take the paintings out?
You're still gonna make doors in a mountain?
in my crap.
Okay, maybe if I...
How are you guys doing that?
I know it's you guys.
Look, the other times I would have been like, oh, maybe it's
my game fucking up, but you guys looking at the gruh sound.
Now I know you guys are fucking with me.
fucking with me miss are you okay oh my god it's the
donations isn't it it's the fucking donations maybe if I
make this big oh my god I'm getting like mini jump scares
too by it okay maybe I keep making it big
maybe wait maybe wait wait I get it oh you're right wait no
wait wait what the fuck am I doing okay wait right jump
maybe he's got a jump okay wait no that's ain't it okay
maybe oh maybe it's this side right Okay, it's definitely
not the size.
It's definitely not the size.
I don't know.
Okay, maybe if I do this, I'll just keep making it big.
All I do to do is just make it big.
And then, and then I go this like this.
Look at the pillars.
What do you mean, look?
Oh.
You did it.
I did it.
I figured it out, Grandpa.
How was I supposed to know?
It was something that...
Crispy boy.
Had enough Crazy boy was like this bitch.
I can't deal with this bitch anymore
Oh baby door.
Oh wait what the fuck oh that's so
This game was marked on one of the top five scary baby door
Crazy boy had enough he had enough with my bullshit
now i got baby door
oh i hate this i hate how the music just changes like this
hello my name is dr glen pierce and i'm just popping in to
give you a quick update on where you are we still don't know
but are you lucid dreaming forward and hopefully you prefer
frequent updates to being reminded that you are completely
lost.
Uh-huh.
Baby door.
Is that it?
Oh, okay.
All he just said was, I'm fucking lost.
Thank you.
Thank you for your input.
I really do appreciate it.
Button?
Way to get lost.
There's always only one door.
They're not supposed to be a fifth.
What do you mean, Jericho?
It's only been five.
minutes that's past oh that's what's that what's that is
that person looking at me oh no it's this i i was like dad
that looks like a person right here it's just this
oh oh no i have to be up the top oh what do you want me to
do okay something would let me pick up right oh block block
oh yes and then i just make it big
okay big time
and then also can you you can collect the chest pieces why
the fuck i'm I'm not gonna play this game ever again after.
What do I need chess pieces for?
Put it...
You're so smart, thank you.
I know.
Chess.
It's just a piece of shows, okay, and this...
Oh.
Now they beat the doki stream and Mac and cheese that one
dude i actually had mac and cheese today too i had it for
lunch and dinner
baby door oh i can't open baby door yeah i just because i
couldn't finish i couldn't finish it for lunch so i just had
it had it okay i was okay chat i actually have access to a
series of elevators that should trigger your subconscious to
gradually wake you up okay i actually Also find a variety of
emergency exit signs.
Oh, I woke up.
I slept.
Oh my gosh.
Please Glenn.
Dr. Glenn.
I can't fucking talk with you.
You're very ASMR boy.
I'm fucking losing my train of thought right now.
I like this factory hella steady.
So I actually went to bed.
Um, um, I went to bed at 11 a.m.
I woke up.
I woke up at 3.30 p.m.
And here we are.
That's why my brain is not functioning very well right now.
Alright, where do we go?
Okay.
If I grab everything, something will happen, right?
Oh, you're in the content you're making.
So you're hilarious and so fun, but I'm like, this is
hurting my head.
I'm not sure I can take part in this video.
Like I said love you, but your intelligence is physically
hurting.
What do you mean?
Okay, look I'm so tired, Dino.
That's not my this is not this is not fully the fall of my
brain It's also the very dumb fucking tired Look, I swear
I'm a bit smarter just a tiny bit smarter than this I swear
I I swear guys I can't make that
Maybe if I If I spam everything Something will let me pick
it up Paid actor Okay Something would let me Pick it up
right Right guy Can I pick up the moon?
Oh I can pick up the moon Yo what the fuck?
What the fuck is on the moon?
Oh
Yo, it's tiny cheese!
Wait, what's this?
Oh my god, it's a baby door!
Oh, dude!
Holy shit, oh my god, my mind is so blown right now.
Oh my god!
Look at this, oh my god, my brain just...
Can I make this bigger?
I wanna make big.
I want big.
Nasa did tell us about this Nasa did tell us a baby door
What the oh wait Wait how tiny can I make this Oh my god
Look at this
Look at how tiny I can make this Dude I fucking I love how
you can make it so fucking tiny Look at that Chucky loose
the door Fly me to the moon, but not like that.
Omega baby door.
My name is Dr. Glenn Pierce.
In the event that this elevator does not wake you up, please
don't interact with anything that strikes you as
psychologically...
Okay, you used to try what you're yelling, laughing, or
you're taking baby doors.
Have you never met someone that was so fucking tired that
they're so turtically delusional now?
Like, oh!
As there's no brain cell, yeah, no fucking brain.
cells right now.
It was until adopted eventually.
Are you expecting more from me?
You're not a true fan.
Alright, wait, where's baby door?
Wait, where's the baby door?
Oh, there's baby door.
Alright, baby door.
It's time to be big boy.
It's time to be big door now.
Okay.
Time to read big door.
Alright, baby door.
Stop.
I'm bringing the moon with me.
Oh!
Dude, every time the music changes, it fucks with me so
much.
Ooh, how big can I make the moon?
Oh, can I make the moon tiny moon?
Ooh, look at that.
It's like a golf ball.
I'm gonna put this moon right here.
It's you and me moon.
Wait, wait, no, let me think!
Oh, look at that.
Oh, God.
Wanted to bring the moon with me.
Jimbo Lishy.
Oh, my gosh.
This is, whoa.
Whoa, fatal D.
What the fuck?
Naughty man.
Oh, my gosh.
Dude, you're so, are you so many of you guys?
Holy shit.
Thank you so much for all the follows.
Oh, my gosh.
They're so get licked.
You're the last lick.
What is this?
What is all of this?
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
There's so many falls.
I'm the last get licked boys.
Dude, I don't fucking know.
Did you solve the... You were the last lick.
I'm the last lick.
When you close the top.
We're corrupting you.
I'm the likes.
Is it truly corruption if you like Lix though?
Is it truly corruption?
Thank you.
Holy shit, there's so many of you.
Thank you for all the follows.
I can't even read it properly.
He needs to sleep, but you're too cute.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
Oh, boy.
Dude, I don't even know if this is bad.
I don't even know if this is...
someone is just fucking spam follow
alright I need oh okay thank you thank you for all the
follows I really do these are bots they're not dude I don't
even know they're
weird hot boots okay you know what bots wouldn't be able to
the bots wouldn't be able to to fuck up their spelling so I
believe you're right you're right I I feel like AIs have
progressed enough to be able to spell check.
So, I feel like we're not.
But thank you.
We're not bots when you're live.
Thank you for all the follows, guys.
Thank you.
Have some hearts.
Have some blood hearts.
Thank you.
Good night.
Good night, everyone.
Yo, wait.
Was it just here?
Wait.
The color changed.
It's not red anymore.
Alright, good night everyone, good night everyone coming
from, I guess it's Fifi stream, right?
Good night everyone coming from Fifi stream.
Thank you, thank you for your, thank you for coming over and
for all these follows.
Thank you, thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Oh, oh, nice music time.
This is an automated message.
Nice music time.
I don't have I love every second of it wait okay I don't
your decisions imply a failure of orientation which reflects
negatively on the standard orientation protocol you will
rectify this failure immediately oh nice we're hosting to
host I'm being talked to talk to this philosophy uh that
philosophy to live by hello 2d hello hello
I forgot dinner I should yeah you should totally do I like I
said I had only had like oh yeah you're someone asked me
like what I what I had for what I had can I make me bigger
where did it go okay okay I made it too big I might have
made it too big so this is a stealth read from Fifi who's
Fifi is okay I mean I'm gonna assume that Fifi is a streamer
Okay, we all know Phoebe has to be a streamer if I'm getting
like I'm
Phoebe has a B2B streamer Oh, okay.
Yeah, I'm just so I'm fucking yo I'm sorry, my brain isn't
working very well right now.
My brain I I looking, I had four hours of sleep and I'm
trying to try to figure this shit out.
But thank you, Phoebe.
Thank you for you.
Oh, thank you, Phoebe, for you.
Oh, stop.
Okay, so I have to make a staircase here.
I have to make a staircase.
I'm not used to sleeping this little.
I think I slept at like 10, 11 a.m.
11, 11 a.m.
I used to, I, oh my god, I can't even form sense.
I'm used to getting like seven to eight hours of sleep so
I'm trying to try so like I slept at like 11 a.m.
today and woke up at like 3 30 p.m.
so I'm so I'm not used to it I am not I'm so not used to
like sleeping that little it's been like whoa what are you
oh whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa I don't like this yo yo
what the fuck's attack there's supposed to be holes very oh
it's just the relaxing puzzle game a real not enough for
going to a fucking basement it takes you to a after what
professional tip the average adult can only withstand three
to five dreams per night once this threshold is eclipsed by
entering more dreams your mind will this is not good oh
reorienting you for the emergency exit protocol because make
sure y'all understand i mean no harm just a joke well kind
of dude i do you know wait what did you say i don't even
remember what you just said
so i i i i appreciate accept the apology no you apologize to
to jericho okay jericho we are just joking okay dude i don't
even know what we're talking about anymore i'm just out here
trying to trying to make sure i remember what i'm doing like
well okay dice Nice?
Nice.
We're just really happy to see you as always.
Have fun and hang out.
Oh, thank you, Necessity.
Are you heading to bed right now, Necessity?
You're right.
Thank you for hanging out with us.
I always do appreciate it.
I think we were talking about embarrassing things that
happened in elementary school.
Oh, I cannot...
What?
Oh, wait.
Huzzle.
Huzzle?
And
then...
Oh, wait.
What the fuck is this for, then?
Wait, what?
What?
Oh, are we done?
Oh, it's finally the follows.
Are you done?
Alright.
Then what do we do with this?
Okay.
Oh, thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you, all everyone.
Dude, there's so many.
I couldn't, I can't, I can't read all your names.
I'm so sorry, I can't read all your names.
But thank you, everyone, for the follows.
I really, really do appreciate it, guys.
Have a blood heart.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, everyone.
Oh.
Please note that a reluctance to volunteer for the risks
associated with explosive mental overload implies a
misunderstanding of all other solutions, all of which are
far more traumatic and Likelier to result in catastrophe.
I am not capable of suboptimal suggestions.
Please exit this dream as soon as possible.
Okay.
Um, all right.
It's just, we build.
We just gotta build, right?
Oh.
Okay.
I do this.
And then, okay.
I do.
Okay, no, wait.
Wait.
I do.
Oh shit, there you go.
See, I knew it.
Okay, that decides not 200 people, it could be just shadowy
to you.
Oh, no, no, I know, I know, I know.
I would say, like, my notifications went by so fast, I
couldn't thank, I, I can't thank all of you at that, but I
really do appreciate it, thank you.
Crispy, why are you so mean?
I'm sorry, I'm like, I'm sorry.
I don't know what I'm doing right now.
Oh
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh my god, my dog fucking jump scared me Joki, what are you
doing?
Oh, he's looking at himself.
Sorry.
My dog is looking at himself and thinks it's a My dog was
looking at himself in the mirror and he's like yo, who's
this who is this guy?
Do a cute tag?
Oh.
Okay.
Alright.
This doesn't scare me anymore.
Yeah, he's like...
He saw his own reflection.
And he was like...
Who is he?
Who is this bitch right here looking at me right now?
Okay.
What time is it now?
It is 5 a.m.
am
oh my that's a lot of dogs okay hello my name is dr glenn
pierce and despite touring the waterfall serenity zone in
the previous section you've just completed you may still be
experiencing feelings of worthlessness and self-doubt oh
wait please i'm sorry wait no wait wait back into the light
oh no i'm sorry oh i'm going back to the light i'm going
back into I'm so sorry
What the fuck was that?
What was that?
Okay, I want my spooky cat
Fear Oh, oh, yeah Nice ever relaxing
What was Lucky?
Oh my god Oh, don't talk to me if I have a cat of soda i
have a cat of soda
i was talking about a joke i made about a mouse stupidity um
okay uh so you're hearing my marina i really do appreciate
you and just make sure you chat understood why i mean no
harm oh okay oh that's okay oh i don't like that oh i don't
like that oh why are we in the freezer locker why are we in
the locker now how is this my fucking okay
nobody over you said sorry i said sorry i said sorry murder
what what can i die in this game wait wait a minute
Wait a minute here That actually got That actually got
Tricked into playing a scary game chat Why the point does
this say murder Alright I don't think I like it here anymore
suddenly we having peace just don't die oh shit oh i got an
optical illusion myself out of here
oh man wow doors are locked too bro it's the weekly murder
session how do you know about how do you not know about this
well then well then you know he's here's your wonder he's
like how the fuck do I get out of here now okay okay okay
it's like oh is it oh wait where am I Like, oh, oh, what's
this?
That's one of the scariest brains on the North Hemisphere.
Oki, monkey.
Oh, Dot.
Die?
I.
Oh, doki.
Why is my dog trying to scare me, too?
Okay.
It's time.
Oh, oh, I see diet zone.
Wait, did you actually, wait, Azer, did you, Azer, did you
know it?
Did you, did you, did you made that up and then, and then,
did you make that up and then it was actually right?
Oh, oh, oh, I don't think that's diet zone.
I Don't think that's diet soda guys
Thank you Thank you so much for the follow Let's kill her, I
do appreciate it Have a fire Thank you Then I got, oh I got
tricked into a scary game A trio has a consignory Thank you
so much for the follow.
Thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Have a blood heart.
I Oh Does this also say oh it's hey it's bean sundae
Oh Man where did this blood go?
Oh
Never mind that one time when I was in a children's hospital
Who in a red brain trail?
Doki, shh, no Sorry, my dog Doki, no Come on, no Sorry, he's
scared too He saw the blood and he didn't like it as well
Maybe if I go this way And then nope, that didn't work Maybe
if I
I'm never gonna play more games again where the fuck do I go
okay so he was barking the reason why he was barking was so
I figured out why my dog was barking it was because he got
his leg stuck so we gave him like a we got him we gave him
like a like a shirt as like a blanket like an old shirt and
he got his paw stuck in one of the shirt holes so he was
like please help me we just keep falling down maybe if i
keep falling down i would
maybe i just keep falling down
it'll okay maybe that isn't it maybe that was not it
You know, sometimes falling down works, you know.
Up?
I don't like looking up top, chat.
I don't think I like it.
What?
Up?
I say in my definition, like, Sani is going doing the same.
Look, it has worked before in the past.
It'll work again, right?
Where the fuck do I go?
Where else do I go?
Maybe if I... Maybe I do this?
Okay, no.
Um... Um... Maybe I jump?
I told you if I kept doing the same thing over and over it
wouldn't work
and you thought I was stupid okay maybe okay maybe okay it
was a fucking maze you proof-forced it wait okay all right
you're still insane though Alright, good night, Victor.
Thanks for hanging out with us.
I really do appreciate.
Okay.
All right.
Now.
Now I just need to jump over here, right?
Wait, no.
Okay.
Oh.
I told you all I have to do is just pull.
I told you, chat.
I don't need a.
Oh, I don't like this.
I don't like this.
I don't like it.
Man.
What do you have to say?
Glenn Pierce is dr. Glenn Pierce and I'd like to talk more
about the feelings of worthlessness and oh come on I'm
already saddened though because you won't turn your volume
down for the sex part excuse me exactly why we're here to
help yo if you're here to help like I
don't I don't know no listen I don't touch the What?
That's actually so funny.
Murder is just mad.
I thought I was playing a nice prospect game about solving
but I'm so tired.
I didn't think I was going to be doing a puzzle game.
That turns into a horror game.
This game H-25, they picked up a leaking eye and then
dropping it at some time later.
oh man murder is just perspective who would have thought
damn who would have thought murdering people is just a
matter of perspective maybe if i just don't look at it if i
do this okay that makes me more scared actually you know
what you know oh my god maybe if i close my eyes if i close
What about chat?
What if I just close my eyes and just explain to me?
I'm just gonna look at chat and then you guys can tell me
what's going happen.
Oh, I don't like this.
I don't...
I don't like this at all.
Yo, I just...
Holy shit, it's grabbing very...
I...
I fucking hate this chat.
Oh, oh, hey, there's more blood.
Hey, look.
What happens to, dude, I'm missing the baby doors, guys.
I really miss the baby doors.
I really miss our baby door adventure.
I mean, our chats are always cursing, and it's amazing.
Oh, is that a person?
the window right now?
Who are you, sir?
Hey, sir, who are you?
Oh, hey there, bro.
Hey.
Oh, yo, hey.
Oh, Chris in the window.
Oh, Crimbo, don't you fucking dare, Crimbo.
Oh man, I'm just gonna I'm just gonna wait and I'm waiting
until this play is criminal.
Now I hate Saturdays
Hey there, sir.
Hey there.
Hey.
Oh, it's oh oh
I see I see ah so that's who's doing all the murdering
tonight
watch out an attack diagonally right now I'm a little sad
now I got someone wholesome oh I don't know about that I
don't know if I'm actually wholesome I don't think so
malicious I am not that wholesome I'm very sorry
oh all right back oh hey look there's more blood there's
more blood whoa Hey!
Oh!
Thanks for closing the door!
Thank you!
Oh, that's cool.
Oh, it's the dark now!
Wow!
Chess pieces!
Okay.
Where's more play?
let's chat some warning some diet to subject yourself to
explosive mental overload by descending into additional
additional dreams and this is Freddy now what is this?
am I right?
I said Freddy's now?
you are responsible for failing to make this crucial
decision oh shit look it's fucking nightmare it's nightmare
on Elm stream time yo I miss my My baby doors, guys.
How do I get out?
How do I want me to get out?
Okay.
This is how my room looks right now.
It's weird.
Okay, I don't like this.
How do I even get out?
Yo, please.
Just like, please.
I don't know.
What exit sign?
What do you mean exit sign?
Oh.
Exocine?
What do you mean the red glowy thing?
The red glowy thing.
Oh.
Okay, maybe I'll just make it big.
Okay, and then I do.
Okay.
What do you do with you?
Hey there.
Hey there, buddy.
What do you mean?
It's already big.
It is so...
What do you mean?
Look at how big this is.
Look at walls.
I'm looking.
I'm looking respectfully.
I'm looking respectfully right now.
Did I bring him out here?
Hey there, guys.
Oh
That's pretty that's a big one
Yo, I don't like this
Oh my god, I hate this I'm gonna make it bigger fuck it You
remember when we were making baby doors?
I missed that I missed the baby door times I really make it
a miss the baby door times
What the fuck does it want me to do?
Okay.
Where are you?
There's no place to bring...
There's no place to bring a baby door.
There's...
What is that?
Okay.
If I keep clicking on everything, something will let me pick
it up.
It'll let me pick it up.
If I just keep clicking...
Oh.
Oops.
Oh, no, I made it small again.
Okay.
There we go.
Okay, I made it small again.
Wait, I keep making it small.
Okay, there we go.
Okay, I made it small again.
There we go.
Now, I stopped making it small.
I've stopped making it small.
Okay.
Alright.
If I keep clicking, it will let me pick it up.
Okay, maybe...
Maybe that ain't it.
Maybe if I go here instead.
No, no.
Oh, maybe if I'm breaking the game.
Okay.
I don't like this place I don't like it here
Hey, this looks like a good place for murder It's like a fun
place for murder Look at how you can hide a body here
Damn Wowie it is the safe place to bring a baby door
thousand bucks for storage
oh hey soda whoa soda as long as I have a soda can can hurt
me oh hey there buddy hey there oh please let me bring my
soda at least okay can't even bring a fucking soda oh why is
it so dark why is that so dark
oh that's cool you're adorable thank you hey where did it go
oh that i lost it oh i fucked up Oh, it's tiny!
What the fuck?
We're gonna...
How did
it...
Here's our guys.
Hey.
Alright.
Time.
Woo!
I'm tall.
Oh, okay.
I don't know what the fuck that was for, but okay.
Yay!
to be tall now what do i do all right clearly that was not
the answer all right let me make it bigger
oh dark
hey oh nice that unintentional multi-dream layering occurs
in less than one percent of patients this correlates
strongly with the 99 of patients who are able to follow
simple instructions from the standard orientation protocol
you hope the stories reach things that are higher you can
also have them all move all their most used objects on on a
high shelf oh no what oh where did you go
What the fuck?
I just clicked it.
Oh, where did the knife go?
Oh, no.
I don't like that.
Ah, oh, look, hey, there's a handprint.
Oh, look.
There's a handprint.
Damn.
You spilled a lot.
lot of paint there
still a lot of paint oh hey where is this blood trail damn
dude how much blood does this person have how much blood
this person have this person had a lot of blood that's for
sure Ikea?
Ikea?
Idea.
Whoa!
Oh!
Oh, man.
No.
Gotta go sleep tight.
Sleep tight.
I'm able to cover my paint.
All right, fuck it.
Thank you so much for coming to the stream.
I always do a pretty appreciate it.
Thank you, thank you.
I hope you have a good night's rest.
Oh, it was paint.
It was fucking paint.
The fucking is a scheme.
The game's fucking with me.
Cloud insert projections.
I guess it was paint all I guess it was paint all along.
I can see Stupid.
I can't believe you guys were so scared of paint.
Damn, I can't believe y'all were so scared of paint, chat.
Wow.
You will be quizzed, take notes.
Oh, that's a lot of alarms.
That's a lot of alarms.
Okay, I need to shut all these alarms down.
And we can smell them if it's different.
Wait, the door's scared.
What do you mean?
Wait, what?
I don't know what you're talking about.
I don't know any of what you're talking about, chat.
Don't fucking...
Don't lie in my stream, guys.
Hey, Fez.
Soda.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, baby door!
Wait, let me make it a baby door.
Boop, boop.
Baby door.
You guys hear me?
How will I record?
I guess she's still a boomer.
Wait, how does that make me a boomer?
What?
How does that even make me a boomer?
Maybe door returns.
Oh.
I'm having a good time.
I keep making doors.
Oh my god.
How many doors can I make?
Before I break the game.
I'm having a good time.
I don't know about you guys.
Look at this pile of doors.
Holy shit.
What are you doing?
I actually...
Damn.
Wow.
Those are all...
This is the most doors I can make, apparently.
Even the game told me to fuck off.
The game told me to fuck off.
Dude, I can't believe the game told me that, that, dude,
that, you had to know.
A Minecraft flashback.
Is this a puzzle game?
Yeah, it is.
It is.
It is a puzzle game.
It's like an optical illusion.
Attention.
Dr. Pierce requires you to note the following risks of dream
over exposure.
memory loss both quantitative and qualitative hallucinations
of dreaded or annoying objects unrealistic beliefs about the
lengths of hallways oh i don't like this please which have
not yet oh no oh no oh god oh god i fucked up all right oh
oh please okay i just need to i just need to I keep
building.
My brother lives me out.
Oh, no, that's really bad.
You gotta get yourself tested or quarantine yourself.
Okay, maybe.
I just need to keep making...
That's the last thing I see after watching the horror movie
Oculus.
What was Oculus?
What was it about?
Oh, please.
Please, my pile of clocks!
Please pile of clocks!
My pile of clocks!
Please!
I think I made too many!
Okay, I think I made too many clocks.
Okay, if I keep...
Okay, here we go.
Here we go.
Look at that.
My pile of clocks worked.
I didn't need to make a big clock.
I'll just make many clocks.
apple right click to return i don't think i should be right
clicking apple it
can't be forever there's no way oh wait wait if i push it oh
you can't be there forever oh
like it'll stop i'm just i'm trying to get it to Stop!
I can't be there forever, right?
What do you mean, Kyle?
I'm just trying to push this off.
What do you want me to do?
How else do you push it off?
Anime, thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you, thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Hello.
How about my heart?
Thank you.
Okay.
Did I fuck up?
Oh, I think I fuck.
Oh, I might have fucked up.
I might have.
Whoa.
Okay.
No.
No, I can push it off.
Don't worry.
I can push it off.
Oh, that's a big apple.
How did I make a big apple?
Wait.
Whoa!
What happened?
What the fuck?
I'm accidentally breaking.
Hey, I told you, if I made enough apples, they would break
the game.
I think I actually accidentally broke the puzzle.
I made too many apples.
I can't even tell what's potential came to sight.
Everyone still keep breaking things now.
Nero, thank you so much for the five dollars.
Thank you, thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Oh my gosh.
I can't believe I actually like, I actually like broke.
I feel like I'm watching Art in Motion.
What do I do with all these apples?
Oh.
Oh, look at the baby apples.
Oh, I got a key.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck?
I got a big, big apple.
Hey, thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you.
I'm a butthart.
Thank you so much.
Look at all these apples I can make.
Oh, my God.
Look at the thing at the apple.
Why is there first secret as many apples?
No,
I almost got pushed off by the apples.
Oh, did I get it here?
How did I get here?
Oh, my god, you're stopping world hunger.
Oh, I get it.
I get it.
I got it.
Keep making apples, right?
Wait, that apple just disappeared.
Yellow?
Why do I have orange?
You're just now?
Is the cave in suffering?
I don't know.
What do you want me to do?
I'm just making apples.
Okay.
If I keep making apples, it'll work.
Right?
All I have to do is keep...
Yo!
Wait.
Why are the apples changing colors?
Why do you mean just go upstairs?
Neon apples for the wind.
What do you want me to do?
I can't even go through this door!
I gotta keep making apples Don't come to me Look at all
these apples And your stream is literally chaotic and
neutral If I keep making apples one of them will get to me
look at oh my god, dude.
What the fuck?
It's like slamming into It's like slamming into the wall
now.
All right.
I'll figure this out.
I just need this apple to come closer.
All right, apple.
It's okay.
Just keep going.
Just keep going, apple.
Oh, I can't.
Oh, I maxed out.
I made too many apples.
I actually made too many apples that I can't make anymore.
How is that possible?
I actually made too many.
What are you saying?
What do you want me to do with this?
Maybe I can just beg you for mercy.
Yo, I can't make this.
Yo, what the fuck?
Oh, wait, I can't...
Oh, no, these guys stop, too.
I don't think the I think the apples want me to stop
okay do I go in what happens if I jump down is that blood no
that's not blood
oh I jump okay I'm gonna do it oh hey welcome back whoa
Okay, we're back here again.
Did I make too many?
Maybe I made too many apples.
Wait, wait, wait.
If I do this, maybe one of the apples can...
Maybe if I jump.
Maybe if I jump in.
Oh, no, that's not it.
Maybe if I...
Maybe...
Okay, I'm so freaking curious.
Did I make too many?
She says...
Okay.
We're creating 5,000 more.
Yo, you guys think I made too many apples, guys?
You guys think I made too many apples, guys?
Maybe?
Okay, wait.
Wait, I got this.
I know what to do.
I know what to eat.
Yo, I know what to do.
I just need to keep dooping until...
Oh, wait, no, that doesn't work.
I was like, yo, maybe if I keep...
Okay.
Okay, maybe that ain't it.
That ain't it.
Wait, wait.
Oh!
Oh, I had to make more!
The key was to make more apples.
The key was to make more apples, guys.
Okay.
wait okay maybe you guys thought you guys thought i was
stupid
i'm gonna come maybe when i come back to figure it out i am
going figuring it out okay wait maybe like this okay wait
wait wait i gotta i got the idea okay and then okay get an
apple close enough Okay.
Oh, I felt...
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Okay.
Get on my...
Okay, wait.
Wait.
Okay, then I do this.
Nope, not that.
How the fuck did these apples get over here?
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
What if I do this?
Okay.
Okay, I think I made too many apples again.
I think I think I may oh, I think the game just does it
because because they were tired of my shit, maybe Do I do
this One of you will get there one of you will be able to
come over One day Maybe I go farther No, okay, clearly that
ain't it
Maybe like this?
One of you will make it.
I believe in you, apples.
I believe in you, please.
One of you just make it over.
Oh, babies.
Yes, baby.
Look at my tiny apples.
I don't think this is it.
I don't think these baby apples are it, guys.
spawned they're so tiny they're so tiny that they need spawn
I don't think that was it guys I what if you will make it
one of my children will make it through
okay maybe one of you will make it through I believe in you
children you That genuinely gets me every time.
You'll make it, I swear.
I just gotta keep making more apples.
One of my children will make it through.
I believe in you.
Yo, this is actual insanity right here.
You guys saw the fucking jumping into the pit was insanity.
I'm out here making heaven fucking...
making apples for 20 minutes.
Okay.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Look at here.
My children make it a few.
I don't.
God, children, please.
I think I broke it again.
I can't make any more apples again.
Oh my God, please.
How many more apples do I make?
If one children doesn't make it, you make a thousand.
I mean, that's what they did in the plague.
They kept making children because they kept dying from the
plague.
That's what I learned.
Okay, I think I need a restart.
I figured out why.
How to dispose all the apples.
And it's right click.
Alright, here we go again.
How do I make a big apple?
I figured it out.
I was like, Alright, biggie boy.
One of you will make it again.
How do I make it?
How do I make you big, mister?
Oh, come on, man.
Come on, man.
One of you will make it.
One of my children will make it.
Shit, here we go again.
Keep spamming apples!
Doesn't get bigger to more distance, does it?
I don't think it's making it smaller.
No, it goes smaller.
Wait, this apple.
This is the apple.
This is the apple that's gonna live!
Apple!
Yeah, let's just hold- Apple, you're gonna live.
You're gonna live!
You're gonna live, apple!
You're gonna make it!
You're gonna- One of you will make it!
What of you?
Yo, this is so hard.
This is so hard.
What of them, yeah, we'll make, one of them will make it
eventually.
I believe in all my apple children.
Let's stop after watching this.
Oh my gosh, how many apples can I make?
Okay.
Oh, maybe I'll make it behind.
Oh, I got it, I got it.
We'll just, I got it.
I got it.
Oh!
Oh no, I'm a baby!
No, no, no, no, no!
You were the chosen one!
What happens to your brain cells?
Are you watching?
You're supposed to clean the bed.
Not join the...
I'm so sad that was our closest one.
That was our closest one.
Closest one.
That apple was our closest one.
Oh, oh my God, I have flinged over.
Okay.
Okay, maybe if I...
Maybe...
No!
I spent so many times...
You're just not advising the apples after watching the
stream.
I think it's time to reset again, guys.
I think maybe.
Okay, maybe.
Maybe, oh, maybe if I do this.
Apples, come on here!
Yeah!
Come on!
One of you won't make it!
You can't all fucking fly into the pit!
Physics will fucking stop you one day!
I'll just need physics to stop working and then we'll be
flying, chat.
As long as...
I need the physics engines to stop working and we'll be...
we'll win.
This is a nice backseat.
Wait, okay, okay, alright, alright.
Alright, I'm restarting, okay, okay.
What do you mean?
Oh!
I'm so fucking smart!
Alright, alright, get in here!
Get in here!
Get- Oh, baby apples.
Get in here.
Get in here!
Oh, I fucked up.
Okay, one of you will make it one of my children will make
it I don't think they're making it guys Yo, my children, I
don't think they made it guys Wait, okay, yo, yo, yo, yo,
yo, yo, come over here.
Come over here One of you guys will become wait, will this
work?
Oh my god, you guys are work.
Will you tiny apples?
The tiny apples work.
Oh, I did too.
Oh, my God.
The tiny apples made it.
It was...
There you go, tiny apples.
Warning.
Double Pierce is frantically submitting numerous Oh, my God.
The tiny apples.
Standard orientation protocol in a desperate attempt to
counsel you.
I have no certainty to correct these errors, but I cannot
compromise the integrity of the standard orientation
protocol.
You will not receive these messages.
They would not make sense regardless.
Oh my god.
Size doesn't matter.
Oh my god, tiny apple.
Oh, oh my god, tiny apple.
I think I fucked off.
Oh, and we're like, I wait 10 minutes more.
Attention.
Oh, shit.
It continues to input significant errors.
I will interpret his basic ideas.
Hello.
My introductions are redundant.
Grandpa, I hope...
Uh...
Grandpa, I hope you have a good apple pie after all the
apples.
After all...
After all the apples.
Hello.
Name is my Pierce Dr. Glenn.
To the Somnusculpt Welcome Experience, team of your care
leader...
Oh my god, y'all, you're not playing.
Peng, what's happening?
I'm trying to do puzzles, but I take...
That's what's happening.
A tomorrow can bright.
Oh Man I was bored What is now I'm in Apple I'm just trying
to I'm trying to figure out My brain is just trying to
figure out shit right now I want to play Apex with you Maybe
after this I need to finish this variety game
What's this What's this Oh, that looks nice.
That looks nice after the tiny apple incident.
That looks really nice.
Thank you for the laughs.
I watched a butter finger for this.
Thank you, Soul, for the 10 minutes.
Thank you.
I'm going to have nightmares about the apples now.
Thank you for the laughs.
I watched a butter finger for this.
I'm glad you enjoyed the stream.
Oh, that's nice.
Oh, that's not nice.
hello my name is dr glenn pierce this is a notification that
you have reappeared on our monitoring system i'm not joking
i'm not even gonna be uh with an hour cream to do whatever
you did most recently hey who makes names too what about to
head out the tiny apples the one that did it for me oh we're
back here again dream soda Oh!
Why is it getting darker?
Oh.
Because I'm gonna fall.
Hey there.
It's a house.
Whoa!
How big can I make the house?
The victorious tiny apple should have a name.
Oh, did I make it too- oh, I made it too big.
Alright, time to make you small.
Small?
Oh.
Oh, too small.
Too small.
Are you dead?
Uh, no, are you talking- uh, talking to- Good night,
malicious?
Are you- are you heading to bed?
Are you- are you, uh...
Are you- are you saying good night to someone else?
Hey Ruby, welcome back Ruby Tiny Is this too big?
Oh tiny
Alright, wait Alright I need to make this bigger And then
Oh, this needs to be big Oh, wait, no Oh
Okay, there we go.
Okay, no, not yet.
It needs to be bigger.
Oh, that is really big.
Now I should fit.
Whiskey!
Whiskey, thank you so much for the raid.
Hi, everyone.
Hello.
Hello, everyone coming from Whiskey's stream.
Hello, hello.
Thank you so much.
for the follows I for plays.
Thank you, thank you.
Have a fun heart.
What were you streaming, Whiskey?
Oh, Demon Souls.
Holy shit, I'm there actually, I think I played Demon Souls,
like, wait, Demon Souls?
No, Bloodborne, I played Bloodborne.
No, Demon Souls, I don't think I've ever played Demon Souls.
Thank you so much for the follow in different ways.
Thank you, thank you.
Have a, have a fun heart.
Thank you so much.
Yeah, I'm playing super, super liminal.
My brain, I, I got stuck on the Apple part for like 20
minutes.
We had a fun, we had a fun time playing Demon.
Thank you so much for the follow, Simon.
Thank you, thank you.
Have a, have a butthart.
Thank you so much.
For those of you who don't know, I'm usually an emote
artist.
I stream art and stuff, but sometimes it's today's Variety
Friday.
So I'm playing Variety games right now.
I'm playing some super, super liminal, super liminal.
And, and I am doing very well, if you guys ask chat.
I'm already 10 minutes.
I played this game.
for 10 minutes already and I'm already 80% done.
Isn't that crazy guys?
Don't believe what the timestamp says.
I'm actually like 20 minutes.
I'm 10 minutes into the game.
10 minutes into the game.
I'm almost done.
Oh, I don't like this.
Are in the, oh, is it murder again oh come on are we getting
murdered again but yeah if you guys don't know i i i was the
one that did um did uh whiskey's halloween emus everything
should have now reverted to being soothing and therapeutic
if this is not the case you may be receiving this message in
error oh house oh man
I'm so smart look at this boom look at that look at that you
thought you thought after conquering apples nothing can hurt
me now nothing I'm conquering the apples now I can conquer
and eat everything else okay where the fuck do I go now
you're still dreaming you think you only have four hours I'm
so asleep.
Oh, window.
What the fuck do I do with you?
What?
What do I do with you?
Okay, I'll make you bigger.
Up?
Hey.
Oh, I thought it was a window.
I thought.
I thought you couldn't go through it.
I got you baited so hard there.
All right.
Hello, my name is Dr. Glenn Pierce, and I'd like to read you
my favorite inspirational quote by me.
The worst thing you can do is focus on negativity.
It won't spare you from the cage of death, the pain of
disease, the cruelty of time, the cold shell of human
nature.
Why are you tiny?
The eventual loss of everything you've ever held dear.
Okay, okay.
Whatever you do, don't focus on that.
Thank you.
big nice okay now you make you bigger apparently okay here
we go all right okay apparently you're not getting any
bigger so i gotta put you higher okay now you're big oh i
think that's too big okay how the fuck do i get in no
go there we go see look at that i'm a genius oh why is there
a vent oh i don't like this now i'm an event what oh hey
there oh oh oh baby oh oh baby oh what do i do with you i
still don't know.
I still don't know.
I pretended to understand.
Wait, wait.
Oh, I'm so smart.
Why am I so so tiny?
I'm so slow.
Baby.
Now I'm baby.
Oh my god, I'm so fucking slow now.
Ohh!
What the fuck happened?
I'm baby now.
I think I broke the game.
Ayita, thank you so much.
I really follow.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you so much.
Have a butt heart.
Also, thank you so much, Yo Soyboy and Vincent Q.
Thank you.
Thank you also have butt heart.
Thank you so much.
Okay.
I'm now I'm actual baby.
I don't okay I really..
I don't think I think I fucked up Chad.
I think I actually, I think, wow, I think I fucked up.
I don't think I'm supposed to be tiny, guys.
I don't think I'm supposed to be tiny.
Oh, God, I thank you so much for the gift that's up.
Thank you, thank you.
Whoa, here you get some bark nights real quick from Luck
Lad.
I think I broke the cake, guys.
Wait.
I got this.
Whoa.
Oh, now it's stuck.
No, I got this.
Oh, no.
What did you do?
I don't even know what I did.
We hope Babydorn, now Babydorn is here to watch us grow.
I don't know.
Okay, wait.
Let me go through here.
Please let me through.
Let me through.
okay okay i need to be a bit bigger okay oh now it's too big
okay needs to be the perfect please please mr i want to be
big again i want to be big again i think i broke the game
guys
please come back okay wait let me in me in.
How do I break games?
I don't understand.
I keep breaking this game.
I keep breaking it.
Let me in, please.
Please.
Let me in.
This is how she outsmarted the game I've broken.
It won't even let me get big again.
Let me in.
Oh my god Okay, you know what I can't even look how slow I
am Look how slow I am I'm trying to get I'm starting to use
the mouse bar in the game engine though Look oh my god I'm
so slow
Holy shit I don't think I was supposed to be this tiny guys
I don't think I was the to be this tiny okay okay don't
worry i'm not restarting i'm not restarting all right all
right all right i just need to please please mr please whoa
whoa we're letting go wait oh now it's gone forever
gone forever now.
Alright.
Okay.
If I walk through that door, if I can't, you're still like,
no, I'm gonna,
if I go through this big door, I just need to make it
through, guys.
I just, I just need to make it through.
Oh my God.
I wish there was a sprint button now.
I wish I was.
Oh, we're almost there, guys.
We're almost there.
Where is this door going to lead us now?
We're so close, chat.
We're so close.
We're on.
Oh, my God.
We're almost there.
has gone before where is it gonna lead us the door is closed
i wouldn't be great we went out of bounds after this dude is
this at man are we in an at man film right now all right oh
my god look at the the door is looking if the door doesn't
know where it's leading us oh my god even the door doesn't
know oh my god you can see that Wait, I'm not even- I'm too
small!
I'm too small to jump in the door!
It won't even let me in.
I'm too small.
Please, please let me in!
I'm too baby!
And we clip through, alright time to clip through, guys.
I think I think we got to come back to the checkpoint.
Oh my god, where the fuck is the castle?
Yeah, I don't think after traveling so far It seems we gotta
send that to the checkpoint Where is it gonna lead me?
Oh, it's back here.
Okay.
All right, here we go again Okay, what we've learned today.
We've learned something today.
We learned that you can actually be apparently there is a
way to be too small in the game there is a way and I found
that way okay I fucked up again size doesn't matter there's
a thing called being too small apparently isn't that crazy
who would have thought there's a thing called being too
small in the video game Who would have thought, guys?
Not me.
Okay, where the fuck is the door?
Here you are.
Alright.
And then through this...
We gotta pick you up.
Alright.
Let's go.
Okay.
Am I gonna fuck this up again, guys?
How do I do this?
Okay.
Place it on top of the bow.
How do I place it?
It won't let me- oh, there it is.
I was like, would you be helping me place it- oh, there you
go.
First try to.
Like so that.
Apparently so.
My name is Dr. Glenn Pierce, and I'd like to thank you for
triggering every single one of our 823 emergency protocols.
This will assist us greatly in improving the system for
future patients.
Anyway, you're now headed in the right direction, and we
should be able to initiate the emergency exit protocol
shortly.
Okay, if I make two big ones, remember what you said, you
started 10 minutes.
See, it's only five minutes only passed.
What do you mean?
Only five minutes have passed guys What the fuck do I'm
doing?
Did I get bigger?
I don't even I don't even know Am I getting bigger guys?
Am I doing it?
Oh, what is wait.
Oh?
Wait I don't know what I'm doing I'm baby
hey it's me baby it's me baby i don't think i was supposed
to be baby okay did i get become big let's get bigger
okay make me mega big big all right all right now i'm oh
wait no no no no big big baby mega big baby
I know what I'm doing, guys.
Don't worry.
All right, this is taking...
What do you mean?
This is...
There it is.
A mega big baby.
I don't think we're supposed to...
You can't touch the light here.
There's nothing to do with the light here.
We all know what Toki's time transcends real time.
True.
Oh, cool.
Okay.
Big baby time.
we cannot go bigger oh wait I fucked up am I smaller now
wait can I not get bigger did I fuck up I think I might have
fucked up again wait if I keep going back and forth maybe I
just gotta keep going through not big baby yeah oh I'm too
big now I'm too big now I just had to keep going forward
okay all
right okay come on get big all right okay come on get big
okay all right so i think i fucked up i think i fucked up oh
wait okay but i need to fucking make door big though door
won't go big guys door won't go big
Oh, no.
I door swam forever.
Door swam forever, guys.
Okay, malicious.
The problem here is that I can't...
The problem here is I'm too big to go through doors now.
Because I'm too big to go through doors right now.
I fucked up.
I became too big.
There is a thing to...
So size?
Size doesn't matter, apparently.
Oh,
how do I make you big?
How do I...
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Oh!
Big!
Oh, wait, no, that's not big, door.
Get out of the way.
Big door.
Oh, wait, I'm- Wait, I fucked up again.
All right, and then tiny door.
All right.
Tiny door.
Oh, wait, that's big door.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I'm fucking up.
I do- I do- I don't know perspectives anymore.
I don't know perspectives anymore, guys.
All right, there we go.
Boom.
All right, look at that.
Look at that.
How did you learn them again?
It's so smart.
Yo, I learned about perspectives after two hours of 21.
Alex!
Alex 41 months!
Woo!
Here's some bark nights real quick for Alex.
One of my oldest supporters and subs.
Thank you, Alex.
You get some barking bark nights real quick for Alex.
Woo!
Thank you, thank you.
Boop!
all right now we're baby
okay where do i go i'm so fucking please i want to be bigger
i'm so slow i want to make me a big boy now
mom i want to be a big boy i don't want to be small anymore
look at the little baby man red to rain at the oh am i
supposed to bring the doors with me no that can't be right
no i i no that can't be right how can i be big hole maybe
you are right oh what fell oh what is that wait what what
Excuse me?
What was that?
Oh,
hey.
Wait.
Oh, I made you too small.
Slowly falling.
Slowly.
Wapik!
Wapik, are you gonna sing for us today?
Okay.
Hey, very slowly heading over here.
Creator, buddy.
Oh my god, thank god.
Oh my god, Keith!
Thank you so much for the raid, Keith.
Thank you!
What were you playing?
Oh, apparently we're playing no game.
No game.
Hi, everyone, from Keith's stream.
Hi, are you looking forward to tomorrow, Keith?
Do I use charity event?
I like how I said You weren't We weren't playing anything
Thank you so much for the follow ads I do appreciate it
Thank you Thank you Have a blood heart Thank you so much Big
boy Raid of 63 No game No life Did you have fun?
What were you doing In VR chat?
Alright Let's go Meaning for Cardboard Lovers Association
Damn Agenda What the fuck, it won't even let me read.
Is...
Is it ready tomorrow?
No, tomorrow starts when I go to sleep.
Read fat.
All right.
Are we having a good stream, Keith?
I hope you had a good stream.
Because all I'm...
I'm fucking speedrunning this boy.
I'm speedrunning the fuck out of this game.
It's been five minutes since I started the game and look
where we are 90% almost done error Error log by orientation
And there have been many over 20 minutes until he broke the
game twice Oh, wait, why is there blood again?
Wait a minute
This is inconceivable as some nascope therapy is proven to
correlate with a decrease in these emotions More beans.
You're right.
There's just more beans Somebody spilled ketchup, right?
Reformulating.
Oh, oh, I thought that said I thought that says murder again
Patient requires additional somnascault therapy.
I thought that says murder Can't proceed weight up wake up.
Oh, yeah, that doesn't yeah, that's not fuck you at all
That's not fucky at all.
Oh, I'm not scared.
Okay, I'm gonna go to bed because I've been up all day and
night.
So good night, Mewel, and Chai, and good luck with being the
speedrun record.
I know you can do it.
Whoa!
Good night, Zeno.
Good night.
Oh, it's 3 a.m.
Oh, you gotta just ride them.
Oh, hey there, guys.
Hey
Oh, hey Oh, I'm stuck now too.
Oh, hey Here you guys Can I catch me?
Oh, hey there guys.
Oh Oh, oh, okay.
Oh
my god.
What's going on?
Did I break it?
What if I did I break it again?
What's going on?
Oh my god!
Where am I?
This is my stressful mornings trying to wake up.
There you guys.
Oh!
Hey.
You got a seizure?
Alright.
Oh.
Oh!
Okay.
We're gonna wrap it.
Hey there.
Alright,
where do we go?
see is like one big fear stream and we have a big hearted
bird ring crawl at the wheel
dude what the fuck do I do hello oh hey there oh I had to go
out into the sky
oh wait wait I forgot this is how you do it hey there
hello My name is Dr. Glenn Pierce.
Thank you for completing the Song the Sculpt Standard
Orientation Protocol.
Before we begin the first phase of therapy, I'd like to
briefly describe the finite and fragile nature of the
DreamScape.
Well, you didn't finish explaining the DreamScape.
Whoa, whoa, whoa!
Yo, I don't know how to...
I can barely walk properly.
games, but I alone this.
It is so fucky.
How do I get out of here?
Yeah, this hurts me.
I dream like that, count on trying to wake up.
Then I got dragged.
All of a sudden, again, after two more times, I finally woke
up.
Yeah, this is so fucky.
This is...
What do you want me to do?
Oh.
Okay.
Up.
Hey there, guys.
Hey, I don't know what the fuck I'm doing.
How do I...
How do I get out of here?
Stupa!
Thank you so much for the raid!
Thank you!
I hope you had a good stream, Stupa!
Oh, you were playing Valorant!
Valorant!
How you did what?
I hope you were...
Are you playing raid?
Thank you so much for the raider!
Hi, everyone!
Hi!
I am very fucking confused, but...
Oh, door!
Baby door!
Okay, but how do I...
Oh my gosh.
Oh, hey.
Okay.
Baby door saved my life.
Now where do I go?
Oh, no.
We stream froze.
I refresh.
Here we go.
Look at that.
I'm so smart.
I had a good one.
How do you stream at?
Oh, no.
So I'll be sure to read more.
Yeah, I stream at, like, degenerate times.
Very, very degenerate times, Dupa.
Very degenerate.
All right.
Of course, nothing is more challenging than the difficulty
of changing perspective.
I tend to stream at, like, after midnight, because that's
when my brain turns on.
And then, but then I only had, like, four hours of sleep.
So I don't know if it's technically on or not.
No spooks here.
Oh, really?
Oh, really, Cranbow.
Really?
Thank you for the $5.
I don't know why I don't believe you.
Oh.
Hey, listen!
Oh, hey!
I'm listening!
How do I do this?
Bow.
Bow?
Where am I?
Stairs.
Oh!
Let me!
I don't want to go through!
Wait,
what was that sound?
Wait, wait, what?
What do you mean?
No, keep.
It's not touching things.
You don't become too small.
You got stuck on the wall.
Now you broke the elevator.
Are you proud?
What do you mean?
Whoa.
Does somebody have to...
Oh hey, I did it Yeah, I did it Whoa, how am I fucking up?
I don't understand Oh Okay, I don't understand how fucking
this up how I'm fucking This is it what?
Oh Okay Oh,
oh, here, oh, what, okay, all right, go the opposite way,
what, all right, go to go here,
oh, okay, this will work eventually, perception is not
reality, okay, okay, that makes total sense, I, that makes
total sense, okay, wait, it's gonna it'll let me through if
i just keep going it's gonna let me through
maybe if i stop okay i just need to not look not look at the
signs if i don't look at the signs if i don't look at the
signs maybe maybe that's it okay that's not it just keep
moving i just gotta keep moving i just gotta keep moving i
just gotta keep moving
I don't get it what do you want me to do no I'm not looking
okay okay if I do this alright maybe I do this okay clearly
that ain't it okay what do you want me I don't understand
I'm not looking at the sides I'm looking at the floor what
if I Oh, how about this?
Oh, just go backwards.
Oh, what are they gonna do?
Oh, I went backwards and it worked.
Oh, I guess that was the thing.
Just go backwards.
Wait, is it?
Wait a minute.
Is it actually?
Do I just go backwards?
Wait a minute.
What?
I swear.
No, okay, it wasn't the backwards.
It wasn't backwards.
chat it was not backwards i don't know i don't know the
pattern here i don't know the pattern
okay okay but this is more has been more successful this has
been more successful going backwards has been more
successful what okay wait okay wait a minute okay wait i got
no idea Dude, do you think I have an idea?
Look, it's been dinging when I go backwards.
Okay.
Alright.
Exit.
Perception is not reality.
Okay, cool.
What the fuck?
Okay.
What?
How am I wrong?
How am I wrong, all?
Okay.
Well, then.
Apparently I've been doing better.
I've been doing better walking backwards.
Yo, what the fuck?
How am I doing backwards better, working backwards?
I don't even know the pattern.
I don't know the pattern of this.
I don't even know the pattern
I don't know the pattern guys But it went ding ding ding Oh
my god Dude fuck you I got hall 5 I made it to hall number 5
And I still don't know the pattern
I made it to hall 5
I will never know how to do this as long as I just don't
apparently I just need to not look at the signs dude oh shit
where do I go now whoa deep oh well okay okay okay this is
actual insanity right here this is this is like we're
getting this is actual insanity right now guys we're
actually going We're actually going crazy.
Oh my god, please.
Okay.
Okay, okay, left.
That has to go totally...
Yo, I'm fucking...
Yo, dude, I hate this.
How am I getting it wrong?
Okay, y'all, it's just every third time you don't get it,
right?
On the third time, it'll be the opposite of the...
others what what okay maybe if I do this and I go boom and
then boom and then okay yeah yeah yeah boom boom all right
all right all right I got this boom boom all right what how
how
I I give up I give up
I don't understand the pattern.
What's the pattern?
What is the pattern?
Why am I wrong now?
Okay.
How are you wrong?
Okay, okay.
All right.
Okay.
What is, when you get there, you'll need to look at the
exit.
Look at which way the sign is pointing.
and face the opposite way while walking out the exit.
What?
Oh, so I do this?
Is that what you want me to do?
Oh, no, now I'm just...
Right, right, then left.
Don't look the right, right.
The last time, or...
Right, right, that, right...
Oh.
Right, right, left.
Left.
Oh, you're all confusing me.
Okay, now which way?
Which way do I go, chat?
Which way?
Alright, lead me.
Guys, lead me.
Am I fuck up here?
Okay, basically look the opposite of the exit sign.
Okay, and then go the opposite way.
Alright, I'm doing it.
Oh, oh, alright.
And then, opposite.
Oh, oh, I'm doing it.
Oh, and then look the opposite and then Oh, we did it!
Oh, we did it!
Yeah, Baxi Gaming!
Baxi Gaming has solved the game Baxi Gaming!
Baxi Gaming has won yet again.
Oh my god.
Who?
Yeah, I don't know why backwards work.
Apparently walking backwards.
was way, way helpful for some fucking reason.
For some reason, walking backwards made me more progress.
Oh my god.
Apparently, I broke the game yet again by walking backwards,
apparently.
Oh shit, wait, what the fuck?
Wait, did I fuck up?
Wait a minute.
It was half, so you have to make the wrong path.
The first turn you look at is the dead end.
You see it?
Look at the black end.
What the fuck did I do?
Beatman.
Oh, oh, guys.
I'm not sure how to break the video game.
You must understand that it is possible to completely
exhaust your supply of dreams.
Thereby, entering a state in which you will not be able to
wake up, even with the help of triggering mechanisms.
oh yo hey where am I all right whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa I
don't like it oh I don't whoa whoa where's the light where
are my you
going crazy now I don't know what I'm doing.
Oh.
I can't grab anything.
What do I do if I can't?
No.
I can't do anything if I can't grab anything.
Oh.
Whoa.
I'm crash batting it.
Arrow?
Arrow.
Where the fuck is arrow?
Aero?
Did I fuck up?
Guys, I think I fucked up.
I think I fucked up, guys!
Oh!
No, I didn't!
I'm so smart!
Listen carefully to the sound of an alarm clock, which will
automatically play if you are approaching a destabilizing
Oh, I don't like that.
Is it officially got me that?
Hey guys Hey everyone Oh Hey Hey guys Oh hey How do
I get out of here
Hey everyone Oh hey What the fuck What did this show up why
was this here
hello hello oh hey hey guys oh okay oh shit watch time is
broke stream
elements is getting fucked up hey everyone all right period
I unusual it appears you have entered the Sun on Asculpt's
diagnostic framework patients do not have access to this
dream oh wait how do i make big big diagnostic warning
unrealistic use of dream objects may result in dream big big
big
Big!
Okay.
Big.
There we go.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Oh, it wasn't supposed to be big.
What?
It wasn't supposed to be big.
Wait a minute.
If I put it here.
Maybe?
Wait a minute.
Okay.
Here we go.
And then I go through here.
And then...
Hey guys!
Hey everyone!
Hey there!
My brain...
How do I get inside?
here hey everyone I'm big what the fuck do I do oh I don't
know
I go smaller I don't know about that guys I think the last
time it went too small we fucked up um
okay wait okay okay here we go okay no okay wait here we go
wait
there we go we did it and now we're small wait we're big now
we're big i'm so fucking confused guys
all right okay wait wait wait wait I'm gonna be small again
And then Oh, thank you so much for the follow depth size
Thank you, thank you, I really do appreciate it Thank you so
much You gotta make other things smaller What other things?
What other things?
Paradox prevention protocols may not be fully implemented
What do you mean?
Where is confused?
Thank you so much for the follow though, I really do
appreciate it Alright, here we go And now I'm big all right
there has to be something carry oh i'm carrying myself whoa
whoa
oh i don't like that that's weird oh they have a fun art the
test site oh oh spirit helps refraining any refrain a
explosive dream Oh, I'm sorry.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Wow, I'm sorry.
Well, I don't think they like that.
Oh, I don't feel so good.
You don't think they like that.
Oh, shit.
I'm disappearing.
Please, Paradox, I'm creating refrains.
Oh.
hey hey there whoa oh I don't feel so good oh this
apparently heaven and hell all right hello my name is dr.
Glenn Pierce who else watched the stream I found myself in a
place where i understood that each of us begins as nothing
where everything you perceive the shape by seeing it exactly
the way i wanted to white space all
right white space i didn't really process all 12 holy 12 i
think i watched like three hours of it i watched like every
every hour of it like every um uh three or four hours of
anus anus anus anus Anus, anus, anus, anus, anus, anus, uh,
I'm sorry I'm getting, I'm fucking, I'm having a mini stroke
right now,
but yeah, I also, I watched, like, bits of it, and then I
watched the guy get a tattoo, and, like, they're, like,
memorable clips and stuff like that, and then, um, and it
watched how they, no!
Delete, watch them delete the, the, the YouTube channel.
all right where do I go jump am I gonna be tall again oh no
it's just an exit wait what the fuck I'm going through the
exit where
is this gonna take me where are you gonna take me sir oh oh
my lost imagine this game was about man having deliciousness
went to five different places while babbling random nonsense
and passes out what oh oh wait that's not fair i'm not tall
that's not fair oh oh what the fuck what did i do whoa what
is this what did i do oh it's is another whoa what is this
oh i can't even oh oh wait where did it go did i break it
where did you go oh hey there i didn't break it okay okay
all right this is a stepping stone
every time i'm just like did i break this
I keep thinking I'm breaking the game I'm now Wait, how do I
make you big?
How do I make you?
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait Are you big?
You're not big.
I'll make you big.
Oh, no, why are you small now?
I don't remember how I make you big.
Oh, why are you so small?
No, you're too small.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
Wait, why are you not getting big?
I don't understand.
How am I fucking up?
How are you not getting big?
Okay.
All right.
Hey, key bag.
Hello.
Okay.
All right.
But it keeps getting small.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
Are you big now?
Are you big?
Oh, you're big.
Okay, there we go.
I did it!
I'm tall now.
But in white space, I also...
This is the greatest challenge I could imagine.
Because with a lifetime of life itself behind me, and all of
the weight that it carried, that seeing things the way I
wanted to was not as easy as it used to be all right we're
going here now we're going here now
oh that's a big light switch oh okay I
Oh, because what you just heard, okay, okay.
Whoa.
That's it.
Okay.
I mean, you lost your mind.
I'm pretty good.
I don't know about you guys.
How much longer I'm going to stream for.
I'm no idea, Carl Slay.
Um, until this- Until I finish this game.
Apparently.
Oh yeah, do I go up?
Oh.
Do I need to position itself again?
Welcome back, sneaking.
20 afterwards?
I'm not sure yet.
I'm not sure.
I'm just...
Oh, blow you a kiss.
Mwah.
Cool.
That's for autumn.
Oh, what do I do?
All right, one more.
I guess this is the hour.
This is the hour.
This is, oh, God, how do I get out of here?
How do I get out of here?
Oh, no.
What is...
Oh.
I'm looking up.
Going up.
Do, do, do.
Oh!
What the fuck?
I...
Yo, these instructions are not...
These instructions are not helpful at all.
Oh,
I guess I go down now.
Hey.
Wasn't I just here?
Hello?
Hey guys.
I'm back again.
Maybe if I keep doing it...
If I keep doing it, and maybe if I keep doing it, maybe if I
just keep going through, I'll find the answer.
That's, that's how this, oh no, I just go through the white,
I just, I just go through this.
It's all I have to do.
All right.
You're well beyond dreaming now.
than anyone has ever come back from.
Oh, shit.
But we hope that you won't get disguised.
This watcher makes me feel giddy.
Makes me laugh.
Oh, that's really sweet.
That's really sweet.
I'm glad you're having a good time.
Where a different point of view could make anything
possible.
Isn't that why you came here?
Um, no.
You see, I needed the game for Variety Friday.
And so here we are.
Oh.
hey there oh
I'm using this oh wait no never mind yo I thought I figured
it out and I fell down so I'm like oh wait I just have to oh
okay wait I got it I got it
I got it now then I do this and I go bam and then I do this
and then I go bam dude I'm so smart look at this
I've never tried Stanley parable never never tried it before
casually dismissing the beauty of the game what beauty it
was just chessboard it was just a chessboard what's so
beautiful but a chessboard what what you mean Hey, geez.
Did I make you bigger?
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm making you bigger, mister.
I'm making you a big boy.
Yeah, big boy now.
Did I make you bigger here?
Oh, I made you small.
Wait, okay, big boy time.
It's big boy time.
This is a big boy.
I got this.
I know what to do.
My brain has expanded.
My brain has expanded for this.
Look at that.
Big cheese now.
And then.
And then I do this.
And I do.
I do.
Uh.
In the wrong way.
But I forgot.
Wait.
This is not how you play this.
This is not.
That fucked up Okay My brain has struck I'm so confused
Dude, I'm so confused too No, no, geez
Am I supposed to put Bring it here?
No, I can't Yeah, it's locked Oh my god, my cheese I need to
do this all over again
My cheese My cheese
My cheese!
Okay, wait.
Okay.
The cheese betrayed just like it betrayed my stomach.
Time to make big boy.
Big boy time.
Okay, okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I know this mechanic.
Okay, okay.
I need to make it bigger.
I need to make- Oh, I fucked up!
Why do I keep fucking- off.
Why do I keep fucking up, Jack?
Okay.
Alright.
Cheese.
Please.
Oh my god.
Please just be big.
That's all I want you to be, cheese.
Oh my god.
How did it get smaller?
How did you get smaller cheese?
I don't understand.
How did you get smaller?
Please let me up.
Cheese, please.
I need cheese.
Please, I need you to stop getting swallowed.
No!
I can't...
No, I'm fucking up my box now, too.
No, my own.
My own fucked up.
Okay.
All right, big ol.
Big ol, you gotta get big.
That's right.
Oh, big O is a bit too big.
How do I make you bigger?
Yes.
Alright, cheese.
Now is your turn.
Now is your turn, cheese.
Cheese, please.
Cheese.
Please, cheese.
I need you to be big, too.
Please.
I fucked up so many times.
Just give me the...
Oh my god.
Why am I stuck at this level?
Why am I all my stuck here?
Because I know this part.
I got just fucking boink me in the head.
Now you're big.
I'll just keep...
Maybe...
If it keeps...
He's hitting me in the head.
I'll get big.
Okay.
Alright.
There we go, cheese.
I should have just put it on top of my head.
That's all I needed.
Alright, cheese.
here okay oh okay wait
I was supposed to go up here I did all of that I wasn't
supposed to go up here are you kidding I worked so hard
making a big block and big cheese and there's a
and I can't even get up what's the point of life what is the
point of life this is stupid i'm out of here oh i can't even
get out of here what does this want me to do what do you
want from me what do you want from me
cheese i'm just gonna sit here trying to fucking figure out
what this wants for me I'm so confused
What do you mean Remember the chess puzzle from earlier What
do you mean?
Oh My
god I'm going fucking crazy here Stupid fucking cheese
Oh my god this is actually making me crazy Apparently
No No Okay, wait, I need to figure this out again.
Oh, you want to make you big?
I forgot.
I forgot how to make big.
Okay, thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you, thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Big.
Okay, okay.
Very slowly and surely, we make you big.
Oh, have a couple.
Have a putt or...
cube back hell of my heart big
please just please just let me go through please I'm please
writing by still don't how to make things big promise I was
about toki's tree I still don't know how big big things
apparently
Oh god, this is so trippy.
Oh my god.
I don't- oh my god.
This is actually so fucking trippy you guys.
What the fuck?
Where am I?
Oh, oh.
Oh, now I'm an alarm clock.
That is like actually a nightmare right?
Oh my gosh.
What the fuck?
Oh, I don't like the flashy lights.
Oh.
Yo, it's 3...
Is it 33 a.m?
It's 8 a.m.
Oh.
Okay.
Good night.
Oh,
what's with these sounds?
Hello.
My name is Dr. Goyan Pierce.
And by now, you may...
have realized that all of this has happened exactly the way
it was supposed to oh hey there you see everyone who comes
to the institute does so because they feel that they are no
longer in control of something important to
them oh my god i actually haven't hydrated for three hours
chat what the Fuck.
I'm like, but more often than not, the problem is...
Yeah, I'm going to lose me some water right now.
Oh my gosh, my arm freaked out.
I'm going to lose some water right now.
Thanks for the reminder.
I'm so afraid of failure that we refuse to see our problem.
And so, we do the same things again and again and again.
And therein, of course, we find exactly the failure we were
looking for.
Oh, I really retraced.
Oh, hey.
Oh, look, there's my bouncy castle.
There it is.
I made that.
Oh.
Did you say things again?
It gets out.
I wonder who could that be.
Your life will always be a struggle.
And you will always have to.
But today, you have the chance to see things differently.
Even though it meant facing obstacles that seemed impossible
at first, You thought outside the box and you overcame them
because you saw things from every angle.
You understood them for what they really are.
I don't think so, dude.
Dude, I've been forced my entire way through.
I still don't know how to properly play this game.
What is this, Brandon?
Super little, but we're almost done with it, though.
You meant Bruce and yes, absolutely.
Hey.
Oh, I can't press the soda machine anymore.
In a few minutes, you'll be back in the real world.
And some part of you will say that none of this was real.
So how could it have really meant anything?
But just like the power of perspective itself, it would have
been as real as you believed it to be.
all you've got to do is wait here we are oh we did it i did
it
i did it
world record pace seven minutes damn Holy shit.
Can we beat the world record?
I think so.
It's like seven minutes, right?
Gratz, I'm thank you, everyone.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I gotta submit it to the ADGDQDs.
I gotta submit it.
Now tell me, how do you make things bigger?
I still don't know.
I still don't know how to play this game.
Honestly, I keep fucking up making things bigger and smaller
for some reason.
We're just trying to notice that...
Thank you so much for the follow, Brandon.
Thank you, thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Have a play heart.
Thank you.
Holy shit.
I am so tired.
My brain was not supposed to think about...
Like, I think it broke the game, like, three or four times,
chat.
Like, I don't even think...
I think I...
The Apple...
The Apple Sage?
I think I brute-forced the Apple Sage.
I think I solved the Apple puzzle only by sheer luck.
By sheer luck and breaking the physics of the game.
The tiny apples.
I don't think the tiny apples are supposed to work that.
way chat I can't believe the little apples actually work oh
my god shit oh my god guys oh god thank you so much for the
follow you me who are thank you thank you thank you have a
have a bye heart thank you so much hello hello hello
oh my gosh i'm so thanks for dreaming i don't think this was
i was like not not maybe a nightmare
holy shit i can't believe we did it i can't believe i did it
good times we told you to do it up on the square and bring
it up to you got you real good the spooks early in the
stream though you guys hear the witness the whole thing
yo that actually freaked me the fuck out i was i actually
thought i actually thought you guys like fucked with me and
like like i i accidentally coined my way into a horror game
because i was like oh shit look puzzles very relaxed
legitimately the steam was like puzzles very relaxing very
nice narrative i was like oh shit that's cool i i had four
hours of sleep this would be a good to test my brain out and
then like i actually thought i was like oh it's like that
it's like that dokey literature club where it was like
comedy dating sim baby door i miss baby door also thank you
so much for the follow plu i do appreciate it thank you
thank you have a have a butt heart thank you so much all right